not only are resorts welcoming back
guests but many are getting ready to
resume
group events and conventions and so is
the las vegas convention center in just
a few months the new center expansion
will host
world of concrete and that is a huge
show joe mohler joining us now live from
there and joe you got an inside look
today as well
that's right this expansion makes the
las vegas convention center the second
biggest convention center in the country
only behind chicago now take a look it's
pretty impressive it is
this is the massive front entry here
this huge windows you can see
a giant screen inside industry leaders
say they are looking forward to june
when conventions are coming back
as soon as we can go we're ready to go
now the meetings and conventions
industry is ready to come back to life
from giant monitors to 600 square feet
exhibit halls
the new west hall of the las vegas
convention center is now complete
we're excited to welcome people back to
vegas and generally but certainly
to this new just beautiful facility the
west hall adds 1.4 million square feet
to the existing 3.2 million
on the third level is a terrace event
space with views of the strip
the other one of a kind edition is the
underground tesla tunnel that will
transport convention goers from one side
of campus to the other
i think it's something that the city can
be exceptionally proud of
i think it causes the convention center
to look like it belongs in las vegas in
the new west hall thursday industry
leaders including stephanie glanzer of
mgm resorts discuss what the future
holds for conventions and meetings in
las vegas as pandemic concerns linger
everybody has saved incredible safety
plans that show that groups can meet
safely face to face
within our meeting spaces lbcba ceo
steve hill says he knows las vegas will
bounce back
in the 12 months starting in july we
have more square footage booked than we
have ever had
in a year
now back out here live world of concrete
will happen here in less than two months
in the brand new west hall here that we
were just
taking a look at and after world of
concrete happens in
june 30 more shows are planned for the
rest of this year reporting outside the
convention center joe mohler 8 news now